Ben Shapiro are you related to Brett
Cooper so Brett is one of our hosts and
we share a pair of eyebrows that is what
we're famous for but also the
intonations of your voice the way you
speak you have so many mannerisms that
really are like almost identical between
you two I haven't seen that but maybe
it's one of those things where you can't
see the air that you're walking around
in yeah she couldn't see it either but
we had all the comments say we thought
that was like a younger sister everyone
thinks you guys I mean my younger sister
classically Abby who's on YouTube also
and there's some resemblances to Brett
have you done a DNA test though we did
do like a 23andMe DNA test and it came
up 100 ashkenazic Jew and I'm pretty
sure that's not Brett Cooper's
background